your new definition of confidence
embodied by the research confidence is
the willingness to try confidence is an
action that's what it is and this
phenomenon has been heavily researched
by social psychologists and there's even
a term for confidence being an action
see there's this positive feedback loop
that happens when you're willing to try
something before you feel ready when
you're willing to step into that
leadership role and put yourself out
there and take risks and make mistakes
and shove that self-doubt to the side
when you're willing to try Neuroscience
research says that you create something
called a confidence competence Loop
every single time you try something new
you're either going to be really good at
it or you're going to be terrible at it
but you always learn something but you
have to try hey it's EV Carmichael and I
make these videos because I need them
because I want to wake up every single
day and get pushed by somebody who's
doing a lot more than me and in watching
their videos it inspires me to be bolder
to have more courage and go chase down
the life of my dreams and I hope it does
the same for you so today let's learn
the seven steps to build massive
confidence
enjoy if you try something for the first
time you're either going to fail or
succeed but you always learn something
and that's where this confidence
competence Loop and the Neuroscience
research comes in because even when you
try when you learn a little something
you gain a little competency right
because of everything that you learned
the first time around it gets a little
bit easier it gets a little bit better
but it all begins with being willing to
try no matter where you're starting from
because if you are the kind of person
that's always willing to try you will
always grow and you will always learn
and the more that you try and the more
that you learn the less you doubt
yourself the less resistance that you
have and bada bing bada boom all of a
sudden you feel confident in this new
role all of a sudden you feel confident
doing a backflip off a boat because you
tried a thousand times and you belly
flopped and you embarrassed yourself and
you got a wedgie and then what do you
know because you were willing to keep
trying all of that competency that got
gained of trying over and over and over
and over again it's how you gained
Mastery see feeling
confident is kind of
it's it's almost like the wrong way to
say it because that's what you feel
after you've done it over and over and
over again but true confidence Begins
the moment you're willing to try okay
and so I I I really think it's important
I can give you another example the first
time somebody handed me chopsticks I had
no idea how to use them was I nervous
about picking them up and I couldn't get
like my fingers to twist in the way that
you're supposed to and it was super
embarrassed and they kept like flipping
across the table and everybody here's
the thing I didn't know how to use
them but isn't it common sense that
there's no way I was going to learn how
to use them if I wasn't willing to try
see being confident and the skill of
confidence is the difference between
saying sure hand me the Chopsticks I'd
love to try I'm willing to look like an
idiot I'm willing to be a beginner first
versus going can you get me a fork I
don't know how to use those do you see
the difference the skill begins with
being willing to try step number two is
reveal uncertainty with Brendan bashard
reveal
uncertainty this one is the opposite
Dynamic of how I used to think of
confidence right we think of confident
people as people are just like you know
it's like Wonder Woman right is
confident we think of Superman is
confident who just knows everything
really what it turns out to be High
performers are a lot listen to this High
performers are a lot less Superman and a
lot more Clark Kent that's what it
turned to be in all the research with
millions of data points in all of my
conversations High performers were much
more likely to reveal things like I
don't know things
like I'm I'm unsure things like how do
you think this should go things like
could could you kind of help me with
this
like high performers literally
explicitly share that they don't know
how it's going they don't know how it's
supposed to go that they need some help
that they need some mentorship that they
need some guidance that's confidence
confidence is not holding back the deck
of cards of your weaknesses confidence
is a comfort with
vulnerability and when people say
vulnerability they often don't know what
they mean when we're talking about
vulnerability specifically related to
confidence and high performance like
measure outcomes the thing that we can
measure and see is that high performers
in group meetings in team meetings in
social situations more often share their
insecurity they more often say I don't
know how this is supposed to go or you
know they they'll be the person you know
at that fruit punch bowl who says you
know I don't really know anybody here um
I don't really know how to start to uh
meet some of these people could you
introduce me to
somebody and that's how they handle the
social networking where they're they're
awkward they they instead of just
sitting back at the punch poow drowning
their sorrows and feeling bad about
themselves they engage the person next
to them say hey you know what I feel
kind of awkward here I don't know a lot
of people could you introduce me that's
how high performers are handling little
situations in life they're not the most
confident person in the meeting who goes
I know everything here they're the most
confident going you know what I don't
know this here's my question what do you
guys
think and that is how you lead
confidently you reveal that you don't
know everything saying I don't know is
power not
weakness but you've been trying to do
too many things on your
own and that's one reason you don't have
the confidence you deserve at this stage
of your life because see I don't want to
I didn't want to start with my
definition of confidence for you because
I want you to be thinking about it but I
like to share it now that we've talked
about defining and measuring the way I
look at confidence is I think the
confidence that matter the most is the
confidence in one's belief in our
ability to figure things
out that's what I believe confidence to
be do I believe in my ability to figure
things out not do I know
things because it's not always true
there's a lot of things I don't
know but do I believe in my ability to
figure things out now there I'm
confident not because I'm smart because
I'm good at asking I'm good at saying
you know what I don't I don't know how
to do this what do you guys think and I
hope this is settling in for you because
sometimes your confidence is so low
because you think your confidence is
correlated with what you
know versus what you're willing and able
to go figure out by revealing that you
don't know got it step number three is
reframe anxiety as excitement with Amy
cudy this was a research done by um a
woman named Allison wood Brooks who's at
Harvard Business School she's a
professor and she was like a Wedding
Singer before she went to grad school
okay and she just didn't get nervous and
she was really interested in stage
fright like she was like why do I know
it's kind of funny she's like this isn't
hard for me why is it hard for you no
but she's she's very confident but she
was really interested in stage fright
and she realized I'm learning why people
have stage fright right she's a very
positive person and I think that what
happened and I I I don't want to like
tell her story for her but I my
understanding is basically that she
realized that for
her the nerves the the so
basically emotions have two Dimensions
arousal level like it's a high arousal
or a low arousal exactly and positive
negative I mean there's more than that
but like think of it those are the two
dimensions and emotions can be clustered
around those so she realized that she
was having the same high
arousal um feeling in her body before
she sang but for her she interpreted it
as excitement not anxiety and so she
realized that it's not that she really
was having a a totally different
experience it's just that she was like I
must be excited to do this it's the
interpretation exactly so she did
experiments um she had people do singing
contests using like uh what was the
video game rockar Rockstar rockar yeah
um uh she had them do like debate
competitions I think they did a math
test maybe different studies but she she
assigned them to say to themselves
before they did the the thing I am
anxious or I am excited and the people
who said I am excited just said I am
excited to myself they did much better
yes so she calls that reinterpreting
anxiety is excitement so reframe it like
so before you go on her name is Allison
wood Brooks hyphenated okay and
yeah so anxiety is reframe anxiety is
excitement and this is definitely one of
my favorites and I think um I think that
that that helps a lot of people also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there Step number four is shift your
thinking with David goggin you have to
remind yourself we all have a story
we've all all of us have gone through
very hard
times but when we're when we're in a
hard time our mind has a way of
forgetting what all we've
overcome I have a way of taking one
second when I want to quit and saying
okay you endureed this so I look at my
life and how I came up as the ultimate
training ground versus most people look
at it as why wo was me God why exctly
why I had to flip this upside down and
say hang on a second God was training me
to be one of the baddest men on the
planet Earth absolutely right that's how
he this was this was my journey do you
begin to realize In This Moment how
mentally strong you are yes because
those things beat me sure but they
didn't kill me no not and I was able to
work around him and figure out ways
through it so when I was in the worst
time of my life in hell week I looked at
everybody and said I'm the most trained
person here yeah well that's the truth
I've gone through more mental torture
than any of you even fathom yeah so I'm
looking at the baddest people on the
planet I'm looking at them like this you
guys can't hold a stick so I started
looking at vers like I don't belong here
versus like I might be the Badd person
to ever come here wow who could have
pulled this
off who could have been given a sewer to
live in in their mind and say okay at
Birth I'm going to put you in the worst
place on the planet
Earth and let me see if you can go to
the top of the mountain right with
nothing right but just hard work grit
and figuring it out and not putting
yourself back in the dungeon every time
something got hard so that's what became
my daily voice was you really are the
baddest person on the planet step number
five is develop skills with J shett
anyone who feels weak or has that
self-doubt it comes from not a lack of
belief or a lack of quality it comes
from a lack of of ability and abilities
can be trained and learned and I always
say this to people if something makes
you nervous if something makes you
unconfident if something makes you
scared you can't just believe in
yourself and I think a lot of people
talk about
self-belief and really it's about
self-respect and self-respect comes from
doing hard things and so if you're
dealing with something that you don't
feel you're good at go and try and get
decent at it go and take a course get a
coach get a mentor go out there and read
a book about it listen to this podcast
right like when you're when you're
searching for the answer all of a sudden
your skill starts to develop and now the
problem starts to feel easier to solve
and so as a dependent especially if
you're single start solving problems
yourself and guess what you're going to
feel so much self-respect and now your
self-doubt goes away at the root step
number six is believe with Marie forio
how do you get the confidence to make
thec decision to do what your Soul's
purpose is telling you to do yeah so how
do you get that confidence to then
actually take that next step so for me
it was less about confidence and more
about I had hit the wall so many times
and there was so much pain in terms of
trying these particular jobs and
essentially failing and quitting that I
just couldn't do it was like a pattern
right and then the definition of
insanity is doing the same thing over
and expecting a different I was like so
I need to change something here and the
whole thing about coaching it just felt
right in my bones so it was this
combination of massive pain can't take
it anymore and seeing an opening to
something that actually felt right but I
had so much insecurity and so much
self-doubt so it wasn't like I quit to
start my business and I'm like I know
what the hell I knew nothing I was
terrified I was so scared and I was
terribly insecure about my age so I
actually um got head shuts done that
made me look about 15 years older than
what I was at the time and created this
website and I didn't lie but no one ever
asked me my age so I just pretended I
was older than I was and that was like I
borrowed a little bit of Confidence from
older Marie to be able to just start
communicating with people and to start
working with people and to start
creating content where I was focused on
creating value for others cuz anytime I
had that spot lot in myself man I was a
hot mess right hot mess yeah it you talk
a lot about to taking the next step just
doing the work to get you there
everything is figureoutable right that's
that's a mantra I live my life by I
don't want to interrupt you but it's
like this core belief that I have in my
bones that served me ever since I was a
kid was this notion that everything is
figureoutable including starting your
own business finding that first client
figuring out how to get a website up or
whatever it is that's in front of you
and step number seven the last one
before some very special bonus Clips is
set up good routines with Dean graziosi
how many times have you been doing
something you didn't like and then
someone says hey do you want to go do I
watch this with kids right my son could
be like ah Dad I'm bored I'm a little
tired like you want to go outside and
play basketball heck yeah let's go do it
let's play horse I'm going to beat you
immediately his energy went through the
roof I didn't feed him anything I didn't
give him any coffee I didn't give him a
speed pill or a Red Bull I just changed
what was on and his energy immediately
changed guess what that energy lives in
us it's always there we just have to tap
into it and what I'd say just start
practicing tapping into that energy just
like be doing something in your house or
at work and just say right now I'm going
to crank up the energy and you can think
about what you're cool out you can think
about your state change your physiology
change your words do what it takes to
like Snap into a different place and
watch the confidence go up watch it go
up immediately and watch your energy go
up again I I do it as like little tricks
to myself I'll find myself low in energy
I'm like create some right now just make
it and the more you do it the more you
train yourself like going to a gym right
you go to gym once and work out and come
out ripped you got to go to the gym all
the time where in your life can more
confidence take you to another level
where in more can more confidence give
you a breakthrough if that's the case
then you need to watch this again and
you need to go through these exercise
and you need to find that confidence to
just go for it to just do it it is
better to try and fail than to sit on
the sidelines sitting on the sidelines
you know when you talk to older people
you watch you read all these articles
and magazines when you talk to somebody
older in their life they're always
regretting and the things they didn't
take action on lack of confidence will
keep you right where you are routines
help build confidence right so there's a
million things I could talk about when
it comes to confidence how you have to
be courageous that means taking action
courageous is just doing it's jumping
out of the plane and hoping the shoot
opens right you need to be courageous
then you need to gain the capabilities
right you need to learn from people
playing at a higher level you're here
you're learning the right stuff then you
got to be committed nothing works
without commitment I mean diets don't
work relationships don't you got to
commit right so you when you have the
the Courage the capabilities and the
commitment that's when confidence ends
up showing up the four CES I go deep on
that in my book um but what also helps
that is a little hack is routines right
so you want to know the best way for me
to kill my confidence in a day is to
wake up and roll over and check my email
yes I have so many businesses going on
one of those emails is not going to be
great so if I want to ruin my confidence
for a day I roll over and I'll check my
email and I'll go
oh man I got to deal with that today
okay I'll be all right like I know I
talk myself out of it you want to know
how I can definitively know I'll have
more confidence in a day is I put my
phone on airplane mode and I don't touch
it I don't look at it until I go work
out until I think of some things I'm
grateful for until I green drink my
green drink with some oils in it if I do
those things and then I practice a
little gratitude I set my day up for
just confidence so sometimes routines
can be your hack to be fine again use
anything in your power to find a way to
gain C confidence hacks are fine as long
as you're doing
it self-confidence comes from doing
difficult things self-confidence
self-love self-respect it all comes from
deciding to do something difficult
here's what happens when when something
hard comes up and you find a reason why
you can't do it it's too hard it's too
difficult it's too scary
scary most people let you off the hook
people around you would say yeah yeah
that's way too hard I mean the fact you
even thought about it was crazy you let
yourself off the
hook but then you
realize I I could have done it you know
like that's the worst feeling in the
world that you could have done
something but then you came up with an
excuse as to why you
can't and that will eat you up and even
if the world let you off the
hook recognize that they have lower
standards than you recognize that the
people who are giving you that advice
and patting you on the back and saying
it's okay you don't need to do it they
don't like their life either they're
stuck they're trapped they're not
pushing hard they're not being
aggressive for their goals they're not
tough
either and we're reinforcing that
Comfort Loop every day comfort you
versus growth you are in a fight there's
a war going on inside you comfort you
versus growth you comfort Evan versus
growth Evan every day there's a fight
there's a battle there's a war going on
and you need to decide who's going to
win the fight it's a daily thing and the
more growth you wins against comfort you
the more you start to grow the more you
start to hit your goals the more you
start to have an impact the more you
start to love
yourself because again even if the world
would let you off the hook you know it's
just an
excuse I think most people think of it
as a giant step that you have to take to
build that self-confidence it's not I
think it's much more about the daily
battles with yourself that then builds
up to Major things just like you don't
go to the gym and and lift 400 lb you
start by lifting 5 lb or 10 lb or 20 lb
or 40 lb whatever it is that's how you
start to build the muscle it's much more
about the Daily building of the muscle
to show yourself who you are much more
than the one-off heroic moments here's
an example so uh yesterday we had an
insane snowstorm here in Toronto I don't
know if we can it's kind of blurry can't
see we had I can see some here behind me
like look see that mountain of snow
behind me we had an insane snowstorm we
had probably the worst snowstorm in
Toronto Canada in a decade I have not
seen this much snow in a crazy amount of
time and so I'm going for a walk uh
rcking and rucking is where you carry a
backpack so I'm carrying a backpack of
20 lbs as I'm walking doing my normal
walk and it's it's crazy outside
normally the rucking alone is hard
enough and I just increased the weight
in the backpack now I there's no path to
walk on and this morning I was walking
through an area and there was Zero path
the snow is up to my knees and I need to
get through so what's what are my
options well I could I could complain
and turn around
right like oh I could look out the
window and say ah so much snow I'm not
going to do that I'll do it when there's
less snow you know and then the next day
there's less snow there's still snow and
the next day there's still snow and then
all of a sudden you just give up on the
Habit right like you let yourself off
the hook to say I'll do it tomorrow and
then and then you never do it and then
the Habit is gone and that's what you're
teaching yourself this is why it leads
to Identity this is why it leads to
negative self-worth and negative
self-confidence because the next time
you come up with an idea
you've already reinforced the training
you're training yourself that when you
come up with an idea you don't do the
thing when you say you're going to do it
and you're going to start tomorrow and
then you don't the next time you come
with an idea guess what you you you've
already reinforced the pattern like I
don't follow through I'm not going to do
that I'm excited today but tomorrow I
won't follow through so this's a snow
it's up to my knees right up to my knees
and I'm 6'1 so it's it's some serious
snow like I got to walk through not
quite that that's that's probably taller
than me uh I don't have to walk through
that much but but up to my knees I'm
looking at it and I've got to go I don't
know 100 m through this
thing and initially my thought was man
why is there no path why is nobody
shoveled this why is nobody snow blow
this like got to get over there I got a
backpack on I'm rucking I'm sweating
like crazy I'm already exhausted now I
got to go through this this is when we
need to catch ourselves right everybody
would have let me off the hook
and another me would have let me off the
hook right Comfort Evan would have let
growth Evan off the hook so it's okay go
back home or go the long way around
where there's a path don't go through
that snow up to your knees and as soon
as I caught it now what most of the time
you won't catch it most of the time
you'll just do you'll do the automatic
thing and usually the automatic thing is
is the comfort thing so usually play
small by default usually you you look
outside and see the snow and not go just
by default not even catching the the
conversation with yourself but when you
catch it this is a really important
moment what do you do do you do the
difficult thing or do you do the comfort
thing because when you catch it and you
make a conscious choice this is how we
start to either change our Identity or
reinforce our
identity so I looked at it I caught it
and said I'm going through let's let's
go you know I caught the negative
thinking I caught the Comfort Evan
coming over walk around go home nope not
happening we're going through we are
going through we're going to make it
through and it was rough yeah I'm
walking through I'm freezing uh I'm
taking one kind of giant step at a time
snow is getting all through my boots all
down my legs I I almost slip and fall I
have a coffee that I that I picked up uh
it's dripping all over the place
and in my head as I'm going through it
it's like this is the best let's go
let's go Evan you got this man let's go
you do difficult things that's the thing
on repeat in my
head combined with
that I'm also telling myself that you
know what not only am I doing this
difficult thing for me I'm also creating
a path for other people that the next
person who comes up against this 100
meters or so that now they will have not
an easy time but an easier time of
crossing the same path so that they can
get
across so it's going to
service if you're ever having a hard
time getting yourself to do something
it's one you do difficult things remind
yourself and two default the service
that it's not just about you it's for
other people now that may not even be
true maybe nobody ever comes across that
path maybe I didn't make it easier for
the next person maybe somebody comes 5
minutes after me and snow blows the
whole thing and so there was Zero
service it doesn't matter it's the story
that I'm telling myself that it will
serve other people that will get you to
then do the difficult
thing so in order to make it
happen there's two triggers that I use
one is language so scary difficult or
hard if you say those things if you feel
those things if you text those things if
you write those things if you're talking
to yourself and you catch those things
then you have to do it you can no longer
accept scary difficult or hard as
reasons for you not to do the
thing because your great life is on the
other side of scary difficult hard
everything you want the business you
want the relationships you want the
health that you want everything
everything your great life if you wrote
down a list of everything you want out
of life everything on that list comes on
the other side of you doing scary
difficult and hard things growth you
that's growth you fighting comfort
you so when you catch yourself saying
speaking writing thinking scary
difficult to hard that's a that's a
trigger it should be a trigger it's a
trigger for me it should be a trigger
for you to go and do it do it go walk
through the giant snow and you might be
thinking well how does that help me with
my business it's just walking through
snow and I'm going to be cold and have
snow in my boots how does that help me
it's an identity thing because as soon
as you start to teach yourself that
you're the kind of person who follows
through on those scary difficult hard
things then the next time that shows up
anywhere in your life in your business
in your relationships in your health
anything that actually helps you
accomplish your goals you're going to be
ready to show up for it you're going to
be more likely to actually do the thing
because you've been training and
conditioning yourself to do the thing
that's why walking through 100 meters of
snow
matters so the first is scary difficult
hard those are verbal cues or or thought
cues the second is the boom boom boom
test where your heart is beating quickly
it's like when your heart is going crazy
like
that it's usually because you should be
doing something you're afraid right now
don't again go don't go don't go
standing on the highway uh because it's
scary and it makes your heart race right
don't be stupid but most of the things
that you're afraid of aren't actually
things that are going to be
life-threatening right they're not
they're usually it's other people's
opinions usually you're afraid of not
failing but somebody watching you fail
right you're going to fail at something
who's going to see you that's what we're
actually afraid of and that cannot be a
good enough reason it can't not anymore
if you're afraid of losing in front of
somebody if you're afraid of other
people's opinions if you are living your
life based off of the expectations and
judgment other people you will never do
anything great you will never live your
great life because somebody always has a
plan for what you should be doing with
your life you will never please
everybody it's not
possible you have to start to learn to
please yourself and it's not doing
something just to show off and just to
prove somebody wrong I'm not a big fan
of of tapping into that energy the
reason to do something is not to prove
somebody wrong or make somebody else
look stupid the reason to do something
is because that's who you are and that's
what you want to
do and so learning to do difficult
things teaching yourself step by step
Brick by Brick one snow uh storm at a
time teaching yourself that will change
your
life
you deserve a better life you deserve a
great life and that comes on the other
side of you doing the things that are
scary difficult and
hard because you made it this far in a
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you different you are special
believe Nation you made it here all the
way to the end and I love you so it's a
special celebration if you put a hashtag
believe down in the comments Below on
this video I will showcase you and
celebrate you somewhere on the screen in
a future video because you are awesome
to see how Tony Robbins builds
confidence check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there and it's all consistent with the
fact that human beings
our strongest Drive is the need to stay
consistent with how we Define ourselves
if your self-de is uh I'm a situation
where I'm kind of what was the word he
used